Some 480 million miles away from Earth is
Jupiter’s moon, Europa, and it’s one of
the few places in our solar system scientists
think could host alien life.
Scientists believe Europa is volcanically
active and the Hubble Space Telescope recently
observed ejections of material from the moon’s
ice covered surface.
These observations provided more evidence
that there could be an ocean lying beneath
Europa’s icy exterior.
If the moon holds a combination of volcanic
heat and water, then there could be extraterrestrial
life on Europa.
In fact, NASA’s Jet Propulsion Laboratory
just announced they’ll be sending a probe
to Europa in the late 2020s — called the
Europa Clipper.
But what if we could get a glimpse of what
we might find when we crack Europa’s frozen
crust without having to fly all the way to
Jupiter?
This is the bottom of the ocean.
The water is icy cold, it’s dark and eerily
quiet.
That is until you hit a deep sea volcanic
ridge.
This extreme Earth location could hold clues
to life on other planets.
These black chimneys are releasing iron sulfide,
and the white chimneys are full of barium,
calcium, and silicon.
They’re known as hydrothermal vents and
they’re just like hot springs on the seafloor.
The streams of hydrothermal fluid can reach
more than 400 degrees celsius and are full
of minerals thanks to a unique interaction
between the Earth’s crust and the ocean
seawater.
They attract all sorts of organisms hoping
to enjoy the warmth, and feed off the ample
minerals.
The vents are home to a curious range of species
collectively dubbed “extremophiles,” which
are organisms that can thrive in extreme environments,
where most life wouldn’t have a chance.
There are red-tipped tube worms, shrimp with
what look like eyes on the backs of their
heads, and other strange looking creatures
living on, and around, the vents.
These organisms survive thanks to the unique
chemical processes called chemosynthesis,
wherein bacteria absorb toxic chemicals streaming
from the vents and turn it into a food source.
This symbiotic process proved that life could
exist in extreme conditions without sunlight
or oxygen.
While most scientists believe any life that
might be on Europa would probably be in the
form of microorganisms and not crustaceans
or fish — learning how these tiny creatures
survive in the cold, high-pressure, and hostile
environment right here on our planet, could
teach us a lot about where to look when we
get to Europa.
So, if you’re wondering how do those creatures
survive on the ocean floor and why they look
so strange, Julian has the details here.
Knowing that there could be signs of life
on Jupiter's moons, should we prioritize a
mission to Europa over Mars?
Let us know down in the comments, come back
here for more videos and please subscribe.